for justice after the police killing of
a black man
the marches follow an independent
autopsy that showed
andrew brown was shot in the back of his
head
his family says he was no threat to the
police and was trying to flee
the fbi has opened a federal civil
rights investigation into the killing
mike hannah has more
another night of protest in elizabeth
city
as andrew brown's attorneys released the
results of an independent autopsy
that confirmed he was shot in the head
while attempting to drive away
this in fact was a
fatal wound to the back of mr brown's
head
as he was leaving the site trying to
evade being shot at
by these particular law enforcement
officers who we
believe did nothing but a straight out
execution
it's obvious he was trying to get away
it's obvious
and they gonna shoot them in the back of
the head man that's not right
that's not right at all man there's also
anger and frustration that the police
only agreed to release
20 seconds of edited body cam video that
showed the killing
law enforcement intentionally edited
edited the video to 30
to 20 seconds 20 seconds and
intentionally blurred out
the office and guns and showed us what
they wanted to show us
the fbi has announced it has opened a
civil rights investigation into the
shooting
and this week a judge will rule if the
entire video of the incident
should be released publicly this
videotape is not going to get better
with age
and you know i think public safety and
decency
and morality and transparency demands
that the police begin to be forthcoming
a nighttime curfew has been put in place
but this has not stopped elizabeth city
residents
from continuing to express their anger
at yet
another police shooting mike hanna al
jazeera washington